[Applaudissements]
[Musique] la
russie va maintenant jeter son chapeau dans le
ring
j'ai vu ce combat de
drago drago est un super athlète je sais que je peux le
battre
hey paula regarde peut-être que le spectacle est
fini tu n'as plus rien à prouver
il  pense qu'il se bat pour tout le
pays mais ses raisons sont fausses
je lui demande en tant qu'ami de
rester dans mon coin
juste une dernière fois
[Applaudissements]
je ne suis pas venu ici pour perdre
peut-être que cette simple défaite
sera un parfait exemple
de la façon dont  pathétique votre société est devenue
pour mon ami
je devrais commencer ce combat
[applaudissements]
je laisse faire
je dois prendre tout ce qu'il a
[applaudissements]
il a eu un combat professionnel et un
homme est mort c'est un suicide
un moment où tu
vas devoir faire des choses que les autres
pensent qu'elles ne sont pas bonnes mais qui
vont être bonnes pour toi
tu dois faire ce que tu dois
faire le combat n'a pas encore été lancé c'est en
russe  ]
tu sais quoi faire
fais le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce n'est pas un mach  ine
c'est un homme
sois plus homme que lui
je dois casser
rocky a de sérieux ennuis
respire
n'aie pas peur
lève toi fils de [ __ ] tous ces
combattants que tu as battu tu l'as battu avec le
coeur lève
toi lève toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous